After "Loki" Episode 4, "The Nexus Event,"
ended with a shocking cliffhanger, the wait
for Episode 5 was excruciating. But now the latest
installment, "Journey Into Mystery," has arrived,
and with it, some big questions. Here's
the ending of "Loki" Episode 5, explained.
It's established very quickly — thanks to
a forced confession from Judge Renslayer to
Sylvie — that the TVA's pruning batons
don't actually kill Variants. Instead,
they transport them to a place in time called the
Void, where they can be vaporized by a malevolent
smoky-force called Alioth . The Void's existence
is obviously a highly-classified TVA secret, which
is why Loki didn't learn about it when he was
asking for files from the clerk back in Episode 2.
In Marvel comics, Alioth is closely tied to
a notorious time-traveling villain who many
fans are expecting to see very soon in "Ant-Man
and the Wasp: Quantumania" — Kang the Conqueror,
and he's reportedly being played by
"Lovecraft Country" star Jonathan Majors.
The big smoky beast had his own temporal empire
when he was originally introduced back in 1993's
"Avengers: The Terminatrix Objective" #1, but
Kang constructed a time-barrier to keep the
villain out of his own domain, called Chronopolis.
That doesn't sound too dissimilar to what the TVA
has done with Alioth in "Loki" — trapping
the entity in the Void so they can use him
to wipe out pesky Variants and other things
that don't belong in the sacred timeline.
The bulk of the episode follows our main Loki
chatting with the other Variants and discovering
what makes them so different from himself,
all while trying to find a way to defeat
Alioth and figure out who's really behind the
TVA. The episode doesn't rush through things,
giving this "God Squad" plenty of time
to bounce off one another, all while
expanding the mythology and development
of everyone's favorite God of Mischief.
Classic Loki explains how he lived past
the events of "Avengers: Infinity War."
He reveals that he conjured an illusion
of himself so exacting that he fooled
Thanos into thinking the decoy was
real, and that he'd killed Loki.
From there, Classic Loki went into hiding as
"inanimate debris." Cowardly and smart — yes
that's classic Loki, alright. But not only
is it an insightful anecdote as to what
Lokis are capable of when they put their
mind to it, it's also a clue as to how the
vibrantly dressed character will have an
impact in the final fight against Alioth.
It all ends in a big scuffle when a variant
we'll call President Loki shows up with an
army of other Variant Lokis from across
the Void's wasteland. However, they all
start betraying each other — because that's
just what Lokis do, isn't it? At this point,
it looks like the small appearance from President
Loki might debunk a few of those theories
suggesting that he's the one behind the TVA. It's
still not impossible, but it's highly unlikely.
They just couldn't stay apart for too long,
could they? Sylvie follows Loki to the Void
after Renslayer reveals that the Void
is a place at the end of the timeline.
That means it's out of harm's way and can't affect
past events. Sylvie's self-pruning shows that
the Variant clearly cares as deeply for the main
Loki as he cares for her. Her main motivation is
finding out who's really behind the TVA, but she's
just not very good at expressing her emotions.
This is something that comes across very
clearly in a touching moment leading up to the
final battle. While Kid, Classic, and Gator Loki
shelter in a hollowed out building with Mobius,
Loki and Sylvie huddle together in a conjured
blanket while they try to untangle the romantic
mess they've created for themselves. It's
clearly the first time Sylvie has ever let
herself be vulnerable with anyone, so
it's quite fitting that she's opening
up to an alternate version of herself. But
she even struggles to connect with Loki.
"I don't have friends, I don't have anyone."
Finally, Loki gets his own redemption arc
as he promises not to betray Sylvie. He hugs
Mobius and calls him a friend before the TVA
agent heads back to work to "burn it down."
Loki and Sylvie head off to face Alioth
themselves while the rest of the God
Squad decides to stay in the Void — after
all, this is their home now. Thankfully,
Sylvie vetoes Loki's simple plan of trying to
stab a smoke monster, and goes with her idea
of enchanting the creature into revealing
where and who the person behind the TVA is.
However, just because she's been nefariously
murderous up to this point doesn't mean she
can't inspire Loki to have a little faith in
himself. He unlocks his own enchanting abilities
just in the nick of time on the battlefield,
with a little encouragement from Sylvie.
Thankfully, Classic Loki decides to give his
life "glorious purpose" by creating a fake
Asgard to distract Alioth. It is a brilliant
moment to witness, especially for an older,
bitter version of the character, to finally
feel like he's doing something positive
in the timeline rather than constantly
being a villain. His trickery succeeds,
but at the cost of his life. However, Classic
Loki points out earlier on that he cheated death
by conjuring a fake version of himself during
the confrontation with Thanos, so who knows?
Once Alioth is enchanted, the smoke clears to
show a bizarre castle or manor in the middle of
a swirling cosmic background. With all the
Kang the Conqueror connections to Alioth,
is it possible that this is Chronopolis? Alioth
clearly couldn't get inside it. In the comics,
Chronopolis lies on the outskirts of limbo and
contains time-points to places under Kang's
control. Will we see Jonathan Majors as Kang next
week, in the "Loki" finale? Only time will tell.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Loki" are
coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.